وعنوان منظمات الحكوميه تعمل بشكل فعال في
كل المناطق وفي كل المدن المنكوبه الجيش
والقوات الامنيه وقوات الدركي يؤمنون
المنطقه من الناحيه الامنيه كما يساهمون
في عمليات البحث والانقاذ وايضا تقديم
المساعدات
الفرقه الذي يعملون هنا يتالفون من
100,000
عاما تقريبا مع مع العاملين المحليين
والعاملين ايضا من هذه الفراغ الذي
توافدوا من عدد كبير من الدول طبعا هناك
مطابخ مؤقته متحركه بالاضافه الى
المخيمات التي تم طبعا هناك عدد كبير من
الفرق التي تقدم الخدمات
والمساعدات الى
هذه الزلازل يتم تامين الطعام بشكل كبير
الى هنا يتم توزيع هذه الاطعمه على
وجبات خلال اليوم هناك ايضا مبادرات مدنيه
ليقدموا هذه الوجبات هذه المساعدات منها
عينيه ومنها نقديه طبعا نرى ايضا
مئات السيارات والشاحنات منها محمله بمواد
غذائيه ومنها ايضا تحتوي على افران متحركه
لصنع الخبز هنا وتوزيعه على
اللاجنه من
المتضررين بهذه
نشكر كل المبادره نشكر كل المواطنين الذين
وقفوا الى جانب الاهالي هنا وقفوا الى
جانبنا نحن ايضا كما تعلمون انه تم
التخسيس ميزانيه
وتعيين ميزانيه
لتقديمها الى الناجين بشكل اولي الى
المتضررين من هذه الزلازل وهذا يعني
نبدا بتقديم 15 الف ليره تركيه الان الى
كل عائله تضررت من الزلازل كما اننا
مساعدات النقديه
المنازل خمس الاف ليره تركيه ليستاجروا في
اماكن اخرى وايضا
بقرابه 2000 ليره تركيه
للذين سيخرجون الى مدن اخرى وياخذون منازل
هناك ويدفعون
[موسيقى]
في المدن التي لم تتضرر في المدني ذاتها
كما اننا نهدف الى اعاده اعمار هذه
المدينه في اقصر وقتا ممكن بعد ازاله هذه
هذا الركام وطبعا ازاله كل
الذي يتواجد هنا في هذه المناطق وفي هذه
المدن
سنعيد اع
هذه المدن واتخذنا كل التدابير الممكنه
كما اننا قدمت التعليمات في رفع الانقاذ
لاقصى وقت ممكن وبعد ذلك سيساهم في ازاله
الاعمال وطبعا
ممكن التسليمها خلال عام واحد وطبعا نحن
فقط نطلب منكم ان تصبروا لمده عام وباذنك
على خلال العام سنسال هذه المنازل
من مواطنين لوحدهم
الى الجميع
نحن نعمل ان تثقوا بنا وان تثقوا باعمالنا
هناك بعض الشبكات الاستغلاليه نرجو منكم
الا تستمعوا اليهم ابدا هذه الفتره لا
تسمح للاستغلالات هذه الفتره هي فتره
تضاغط علينا ان نتضامن علينا ان نكون قلبا
واحدا علينا
نقف مع شعبنا كتفا الى كتف وبالتالي هناك
بعض المنصات على موقع التواصل الاجتماعي
يقوم بنشر بعض الاخط الاخبار الكاذبه
ويستفزون الشعب ويستفزون ايضا عواطف
الشعبيه هذه المرحله لا تسمح لهم ارجوكم
لا تسمحون لهم هناك فتره صعبه نحن نعيش
هذه الفتره نعيش هذه التحديات هناك بعض
المستغلين التجاريه وسياسيا وعاطفيا لا
نسمح لهم ولكن الوجدان الانساني يسجلهم
الان اعلنا حاله الطوارئ كما تعلمون من
اجل
الكارثه هناك عمليات نهب المراكز التجاريه
والمحال التجاريه لن نسمح لذلك الشعب
التركي لن يمس هذه
السلعه
لو طالبوا بهذه السلع والمحتاجين لو طلبوا
بهذه السلع فكانت هذه الاسواق بالفعل كرست
كل موادها كل سلعها الى هذه لماذا نحن
نقدمها المساعدات لان الشعب التركي الشعب
وفي الشعب التركي شعب له الوفاء المسؤوليه
ودائما يساعد المظلومين
لا يستطيع ان يبقى
هنا مكتوب الايدي امام هذا هذه الكوارث
وهذا الزلزال وبالتالي
[موسيقى]
جيدا ان بعد العسر يسرا وبعد كل ظلام هناك
ضوء هناك بصيص امل فهناك
فرج باذن الله تعالى نحن نعاني الان في
فتره عصيبه نعيش في فتره عصيبه جدا باذنه
تعالى
سنتغلب على هذه المسار طبعا
كما حصل في الكوارث الاخرى كما حصل في
الاخر
الى جانب كل المواطنين
واسال الله
هذا البلاء
يرحمه امواتنا وان يرحم امواتنا
هنا في هذه المناطق افاد هنا الوزراء هنا
العاملين هنا
الجميع يعمل على قدم وساق هنا دون كلل اول
اشكر الجميع فليوفقنا الله ويعيننا باذنه
تعالى